[音楽]
ハーイみんながごんちわぁ
me
はいありがとうございまーす紙芝居での人です
それではですねまず最初はあのはじまりの歌からいきたいとおもいます
それでは行きますまず最初ははじまりの歌
トリガー皆さんと一緒にひどいさあ歌える諏訪
歌ってみてください
[音楽]
先針の歌始まりの
らぁぁ
me
ヒョリンパミーナれ痛くよアトピーの te ni のミスター
さあそれはキャンプ by 始まりああ
[音楽]
はいではですねちょっとまずは僕の自己紹介から差してください
僕はですね今からやる紙芝居をしています
好きな食べ物唐揚げ白飯特技は忘れ物
紙芝居の4市とですよろしくお願いします
ありがとうございますではですねちょっとねちょっといろいろしゃべる前にまずは僕の
紙芝居を見ていただけたらなと思っておりますそれでは行きます
いきなりこれで最初で最後の紙芝居になります
その紙芝居があっこれですじゃーん
開きがクイズという
これ始めている人ので見る人もたくさんいると思いますのでちょっとどういうものか
説明をしたいと思います
まず僕が曲に合わせて歌います
その時にこの株芝四白ふざけめくります
するとここに何かの絵が出てくるのでわかった人は大きな声で答えてみてくださいと
いう紙芝居です
これいたを紙芝居ですよねみんなで心配で手拍子をお願いします
プーップーッバーンッ婆じゃ皆さんそのままで良質付けてくださいね
そこだけますよ
チラチラ杭ぶー
re チラチラチラチラ
杭通知が家がチラチラ
ウイッグさぁ今日は流れてくれた
[音楽]
チラッ
ネター
あったより早いでしょ
ねまだ後ろの人がポカーンとした顔してるからね
もう一回説明するね歌います一瞬ちらっとしますそれをシンプルにあってるって言う
クズですからね
じゃあもう1回いきますよよく見て下さいよせーのチラッ
じゃあちょっとあってますねはいそこの白い服を着ている状態がた
はい
はになるほど
隣の方
カエル ok それでは答えを見る日ます
ん
ああああああ
[音楽]
h 後ガチガチなう5うちガチガチ明
みーつーさあこんな感じでキラキラというと難しくなりますよ
子やっ
何でしょう
たてますねそこのチェックの洋服を着ている女性だからっ
帽子なろう
後ろは方はさ
あんだが圧縮されたなるほどねー
女の意見ですねー
スペシャルサービスしますいきますよせーの違う
ちょっと当てますよ白い洋服を着ている女性の方
イルカ
ok それは答えを見てみます
えっ
答えはああああ
市立ガチダチら3つ打ちがチラチラチラ
軍通知がもっと難しくなりますよ
ふわぁあるなぜ言っちゃ
ちょっと今よそ見してみてなかったって言う人
をちゃんと見てよー一瞬が大事な奴なんだからね
じゃあもう帰るよ
の
さすがにもう大人ですからね皆さん高されませんねじゃあ行きます予定のチラッ
さあ何でしょう
聞きますようじゃさっき当てた隣のだぜのかな
魚
ギャ後ろの女性の方はいい
うでー
てみたいと思います
筆か
で聞いてみたいと思いますでは不便だと思うひとっ
多いですねでは魚だと思うひとっ
はよう系それでは答えを見てみます
ん
バイバイわああああ
[音楽]
あっはっはー
i am
抱きが唯一打太刀で
椎名光哲ちゃんフェイスこれでカードの空地になりますよ
しらっ
何でしょう
じゃあちょっと当てますよさっきは出た白い女性の後ろの方なんだから邪気の
わからない
じゃあもう書きますよスペシャルヒント生の子だ
後ろの女性のかだ
うさりああ
じゃ
じゃあその隣の方
何
うさぎあーやっぱこれ簡単好きだからなぁ
よしそれじゃ答えを見ておりますね
状態は者が地金が出てください
じゃ航空デー
hane
キラキラみー通知 datura きらきらっ
ん
wii いったぁぁ
ありがとうございました
[音楽]
はいこんな感じでですね僕の紙芝居はですね
紙芝居と音楽を合体させた全員参加型の紙芝居パフォーマンスになります
でね今観ていただいたねチラチラ空じゅなんですけれども
実はですね今回テックスのテーマがですね step by step ということ
ですねまぁ
ステップ飛び跳ねるということでですね飛び跳ねる生き物をテーマに新しく紙芝居を
作ってみました
ではですねこの辺で少し僕もお話をさせていただきたいと思います
僕はですね12年間紙芝居のプロとしてねこれでご飯を食べさせていただいております
でそのうち9年間はですね今日一番最後に出てきます
ミュージシャンヒューたと一緒にユニットの紙芝居をしておりました
それでですね今はですねちょっと新しくねもっともっと自分を磨きたいなということと
どんどん新しい挑戦をしていきたいなということでその紙芝居に力を入れて活動して
おります
そして今日僕がねお話ししたいことはですね
6割できたら
動いてみよう
でですねあの
6割できたら動いてみようという派
はしです
僕はですねあの21歳の頃都会から田舎に帰ってきました
あのその当時ね卒業と同時にプロのアーティストとして活動していましたが
その当時1月3000もねええで稼ぐことはできず
昼と夜のアルバイトばかりしていました
でそんな僕にね唯一持ってい
ものと言えば誰にも負けない強い心だしと後
すごい強い不安とプレッシャーでいっぱいでした
でねそんなとき
出会ったのが明治維新はシューティングだだったんです
僕は実は公明でもともと
シャイ出身でものすごい引っ込み思案なんです
そんな自分がすごくやでー
明治者有谷お願いして自分の作った絵本に音楽をつけて自分で読み聞かせをしてみよう
と思いました
ねねもともとねやってみたいっていう気持ちが強かった僕はですね
練習を1回だけしてですね
早速すぐ本番です
初めてのライブはですねさすがに人の目を見んめきとの目を見ることはできませんでし
たがそれでも何とか成功
口コミで紙芝居もねヨガっていきま
であのその時ね僕はとっても大切なことに気がつきました
それは
動けば変わる
ということでした
分かった僕はですねあの最初は1割2割でね
動いていたんですけれども最近はねやっぱ6割ぐらいで動き出すと一番ちょうどいいん
じゃないかなと思う
でそんな時にね
一つの大きなペンキがありました
それは当時お付き合いをしていた彼女と
したいなということでした
それでね動けば変わる
というね不思議な魔法知った僕はですねさっそく動いてみました
まあ側から所今の実は僕の奥さんになるんですけれども
彼女はね
お父さんに早速会えに行きましたそしてお父さんに
結婚させてくださいと言いま
するとねおとうさんはこう言いました
よっしゃくん
ここはいいけど結婚するならちゃんと就職して稼がなきゃダメだよ
でもね僕は結婚めちゃめちゃ死体があって思ってたんで
もう迷わず即答で
灰音さんわかりました
働きますと言いましたそして紙芝居はさっと止め
就職しました
でもですね僕もともとボコボコな人間なんで
共にね仕事が続かないんです
1日目2日目3日目どんどん元気がなくなってですね
退職してしまいました
でもですね実
僕にとって悪いことは悪いことではなかったんです
就職したおかげであの
すごいね
ピアノ
宿したおかげですごいの信頼を得ることができましたね
アパートを借りることができたし本当にね可愛いお嫁さんをゲットすることができまし
た
結婚詐欺みたいになっちゃったんですけれどもね
でねそれからはですねもっと自分のやってみたいことをしっかりやろうということです
ね
週3回午前中に終わる牛乳配達のアルバイトに変更しました
でねするとねそこでまた大きな問題が起こりました
それはですね q たがせっかく紙芝居の仕事を持ってきてくれたのに実は僕
根が真面目ですね
全部月水金牛乳配達があるんですってね断って
たく紙芝居をしないということで
でキュートにねそんな事本末転倒だよって怒られましたね
で奥さんに相談してだねぇ
そんなのをやめてしまえと言われましてねで
若干みんなねああ
クレイジーだなぁと思いましたけれどもまあその動けば変わるというね
方思い出しましてもう1回ジャブ自分で信じてみよう
の
とってね動き出しました
で僕のねちょっと器を喩え話なんですけれどもコップに例えますと
もともと中入っていたコップ8割のバイトでした
バイトというお水でした
その水を全部
ってね捨ててしまったですね
開いた8割のところに
このしたい仕事がじゃぁ後たくさん流れ込んできました
それでですね今ではね本当に自分のしたいことだけでは
ご飯が食べられるようになり本当に楽しい人生を送れるようになりました
でもし皆さん今ねちょっとでも迷ってて
でももう六割できているいう方がねいましたらね
新しい一歩を踏み出してみてください
動けば
四季な魔法で変わります
今日は僕の話を聞いて頂きまして本当にありがとうございました